are you looking at all at the ECB right
now last week I know when you had dinner
with Ben Bernanke other attendees walked
out and said I'm nervous about Europe I
don't think they can do whatever it
takes
are you paying attention are you worried
look as many of you know the risk of you
too modest one of our major positions is
assured on the euro dollar so I will say
that we sort of guessed right on that
and I think Europe has major problems I
mean we own companies there Western
Europe is really a problem and and again
there's a little bit of what I talked
about Atlantic City you know you have to
get realistic and I mean the thing about
Linux City on just say again is we're
not really hurting about it I mean these
people you know I have to understand I
mean the unions I just tell them a lot
of hogwash the löwe of the low-priced
ones are lower priced employees are
better off if if they go to the Obama
care thing with you so Europe is the
same thing you can't you you have to get
realistic in France and Spain until they
do I'm staying too short the euro dollar
well then fundamentally Europe has had
problems for years look at the
peripheral countries look at
unemployment but we've been ignoring it
because of LTRO because an ECB
intervention has that is the reality
that it's ended up hurting the European
economy because we've ignored the fact
that much of it is a rotting pile of
garbage well you're being yeah he'll be
a much worse than I am
I don't think it's a right pile of
garbage something wasn't Northern Europe
is pretty good actually Scandinavia is
pretty good I think that some of these
company countries have to get realistic
and I think they might I mean the ECB is
finally lowering interest rates and
they're lowering them pretty
dramatically and if they do maybe
that'll be a time when you cover
right now I think your doll is too high